so hello thank you for being here
especially so early I know it's early in
the morning and I appreciate you coming
waking up and coming to this weird talk
had a Python conference so emotional
intelligence for engineers so oh no just
the elephant in the room this is a
Python conference so who's this lady and
why is she here to talk to us about our
feelings well I'm glad you asked
so I hypothetically so my name is April
Wenzel and I'm a software engineer and I
have been for the past decade I worked
in a number of different startups in
Silicon Valley and I've led engineering
teams including some using Python for
some interesting stuff in machine
learning to detect autism the kids do
other things with Python pigs and Python
and as far as why I'm here so every talk
at this conference is really about how
to become a more effective developer and
I think that this talk is no different
because I truly believe that emotional
intelligence it's key to becoming the
most effective developer that you can be
also I know that the Python community is
a big fan of inclusion especially in
recent years and so emotional
intelligence is key to creating
inclusive environments so learn more
about me I come from San Diego I took
this picture the day before I left it's
all this water coming from the sky is
there any foreign to me but I'm trying
to make do other than that I'm very much
enjoying your city so I just tried to
slice the sunflower cafe a
recommendation from Justin Hoover and it
was delicious this is all vegan it's a
barbecue sandwich and you can see the
casserole just amazing so very very
happy to be here in your city ok so I
want to go over the plan for this talk
I'm gonna talk about what emotional
intelligence is why you should care
about it I'm gonna focus a lot of time
on that cuz I think it's important and
how you develop it so my company is
called compassionate coding and I do
workshops on emotional intelligence for
engineers but before all that I used to
be kind of jerk I have detailed my jerk
days in this blog post which has
actually gotten some attention online
including some attention on reddit where
people are not always the most
emotionally intelligent in their
communication so I got some interesting
jerky comments autopost about being a
jerk
but that's okay because that none of
them are his jerky is leaves that I am
to myself so but anyway in this post I
talk about how I used to be very focused
on just the technical side I thought
okay if I'm perfectly logical and
rational because of course I am right
and programmer then I don't have to
worry about other people's emotions
that's their problem they're offended by
what I say that's their problem I also
you know so I was so totally focused on
that I have very not emotionally
intelligent actively anti emotionally
intelligent so I've mentioned this
because to all the any of the negative
nancies or Nettie's in the audience who
are thinking this is a stupid soft talk
I assume there probably aren't that many
of you because you chose to be here but
if you came just to heckle I encourage
it but let's save it to the end so that
bless distracting for everyone else but
yes so if you are feeling that skeptical
I understand I have deep empathy for you
because I also would have made fun of
this talk and thought it was silly so
please bear with me so the one exception
to the not heckling is I'm trying to
avoid using guys for mixed gender groups
so this I would say this is not a
picture of guys this photo comes from
this great site women in women of color
and type attack calm we can access stuff
that is done at women in color tech I
would also say that this is not a group
of there is also not a group of ladies
so I'm gonna try to use these terms
folks everybody everyone people all in
because in the south and from Texas
y'all friends a team so if you hear me
say guys when I'm referring to a mixed
gender group or a group of unknown
gender then just raise your hand and
because I want to get better so thank
you for helping me out with that
so those feel intelligence what is it
I'd like to talk about what it's not so
it's not just being fake it's not just
being nice it is not ignoring logic and
reason this is I thought this is a
really cool picture it supposed to be a
Rubik's Cube then destroy itself we're
not destroying or forgetting logic and
reason it's not sugar coating so this is
what I used to think it was and that's
why I hated it so much because I was
like we should just be too
to each other we shouldn't be
sugarcoating and it turns out it's not
sugarcoating so steady clear it's not
that it also doesn't mean being an
extrovert or a social butterfly I get
that sometimes where people think well
I'm an introvert I'm an introvert okay
and I am definitely by no means a social
butterfly and I still think you're able
to build emotional intelligence so it's
not that it's also not being completely
ruled and dominated by you know your
emotions your unbridled and bridled
emotions I posted about giving this talk
on LinkedIn and some honked and also
gets get some interesting trolls but
somebody comments it and they're like
you know ya motions are great and all
but we don't want to be but it's
important to you know to keep them in
check and I'm like that's what emotional
intelligence is about so why would you
anyway so it's not being ruled by your
emotions emotional intelligence is the
ability to understand and manage
emotions which I'm using the word
emotion in it so it's not a great
definition so to go give more specifics
these are some of the examples of
aspects of emotional intelligence
self-awareness confidence empathy
achievement collaboration motivation
resilience conflict management ton of
other things but those that's the kind
of them genre they're talking about you
may know them by the term soft skills
this is the term that I hate and I very
rarely use the word hate because I think
it adds a lot of negativity the world
but I'm using it here because I feel
that's dispassionately about it I hate
the word soft skills
what because one softness it's has
become associated with weakness in our
culture so we say things like he's gone
soft
to me and you know he's gotten weak or
something like that I also think it's
weirdly associated just with women so in
the early 90s there were these
commercials come see the softer side of
Sears and it was when Sears introduced
in addition to the hardware that they
were selling accessories and clothing
for women and it's not that soft skills
being associated with women is bad
because women are bad but rather because
it's a limited view and I think soft
skills quote our emotional intelligence
really is for everyone not just women
not just people you know who identify
with their femininity it's really for
everyone to illustrate this I had
I this example was gifted to me by the
universe because when I was on my way to
another conference where I was getting
this talk I stepped onto an airport
shuttle and they were talking about the
Super Bowl and they were talking about
Doug Peterson who I guess is the coach
of the Eagles and since they wanna cut
this slide in if they have lost he was
taking it out but they said Doug
Peterson really has emotional
intelligence he recognized that word but
that turnaround is so excited he
recognizes that football is not just a
tactical game but a psychological game
and I was just like yes
if emotional intelligence is associated
football then how can we possibly call
it a soft skill so soft skill so please
stop calling them soft skills please
please please please also call the
people skills because people skills has
become the punchline of jokes so this is
from the movie office space and the
people who have come to do layoffs ask
him ask this guy what his job is
I just got a bit of Dom so they asked me
what he does and he mentions that he
takes requirements from the customer and
takes them to the engineers and he it
says maybe they acts like confused and I
have people skills and so it's you know
people skills it's easy to make fun of
because it's become kind of cliched
coentrão
so instead I recommend that we use this
term catalytic skills now this comes
from a talk that I saw by Daniel Goleman
he was getting a talk at Google and you
can watch it on YouTube this link and he
says he calls them catalytic skills
because they help us catalyzed our
technical skills meaning to help us
acquire new technical skills and apply
them more effectively so so I think I
would love it if we ditch the term Sox
Bill Vol together call them catalytic
skills ok so why should you care about
any of this so let's talk about why
software projects fail so this data this
is a subset of reasons that project
software projects fail they the
application developer developer's
Alliance surveyed
850 software developers smoked each
group but whatever somewhere to start
from and here's some of the reasons that
they gave
so the ones in blue you'll see changing
or poorly documented requirements poor
team organizational management developer
churn or loss of key talent these are
all things that would benefit from
emotional intelligence the way on the
end not insignificant but less than the
others
you have immature dev tools and
application platforms but I feel like a
lot of the discourse in tech is around
how to optimize the dev tools and
application platforms and really that's
not not my software projects are failing
I mean some of them are that's one
reason but largely it's it's more on the
human side that our projects are failing
and you can read more and that's very
clear another study so they the in 1994
but it's still highly relevant you still
haven't fixed it there's this paper that
came out the essential competencies of
software engineers and there's very tiny
table that's not important to you all
right now but you can access the paper
there and again I'm gonna put these
slides up but the top three how much of
the tea is the palest that are that
exceptional software engineers are team
oriented they seek help and they help
others Wow okay so that those are all
aspects of emotional intelligence
another reason you should care so it
seems like every week there's a new
article about burnout in tech I've also
written one which is accessible there
and I think that's because burnout
really happens when we're not able to
control our responses to situations and
when we feel a kind of powerless and
emotional intelligence can really help
with that so I know we like to think I
certainly used to think that I came to
work and I shut off my emotions
I'm completely rational completely
logical you know I'm just debating
issues using you know pure reason and
it's just not true so I hate to break it
to you you're not a robot
you're not none of you you're human
being and every single human being has
emotions every single one Apple CEO Tim
Cook in a commencement address last year
said I'm not worried about artificial
intelligence giving computers the
ability to think like humans I'm more
concerned about people thinking like
computers so even if we could think like
robots it wouldn't be a good idea
because we're humans and we need to
to care about each other so as a
software engineer here are some of the
things that you do on a daily basis
potentially that could benefit from
emotional intelligence if you think
effective feedback and code reviews
naming variables is really benefits from
empathy designing api's also benefits
from empathy which is an aspect of
emotional intelligence negotiating with
designers or product managers rallying
support for a new tool quick story there
I was at a company and we were using a
remote conferencing tool called sakoku
and the quality was really bad and it
was just it was always crashing because
of how big our team was so some of us
that suggested we use zoom and we did
this we prepared this very logical
document spreadsheet comparing the pros
and cons and we you know trying to rally
support and everyone was so emotional
about it and it turned out that it
wasn't because of the pros and cons you
know they weren't convincing because the
people who like to poco so much felt
that it helped them feel more a lot they
contributed to their sense of belonging
on the team because it had this like
these little office pictures of little
offices like a virtual office and for
some reason they had they had grown
emotionally attached to this tool and so
their response was so emotional because
of that so it was hard so we need to
elevate the conversation from just a
purely rational level to really address
it on a human level
so even rallying support for a new tool
a new framework in benefit from
emotional intelligence also being able
to motivate yourself to learn new skills
interviewing candidates definitely a big
one here to be able to put people at
ease into not rule out people unfairly
through your interview style and also to
mentor new hires I would also suggest
that the agile manifesto is a way of
layering emotional intelligence on to
software development so I went through
all of the principles of the agile
manifesto and called out which elements
of emotional intelligence each one
addresses so here's just one example so
one of the principles is we both know
changing requirements even late in
development agile processes harness
change for the customers competitive
advantage in this because the empathy
service service orientation adaptability
optimism and initiative which are all
aspects
little intelligence so Jerry Weinberg
wrote this great book the psychology of
computer programming in the early 70s
and he said it is possible to be too
smart for programming if the person is
not smart enough to use this
intelligence
to modify the social behavior and
methods of conversation I thought it is
a nice quote and it was the 70s which is
why it uses his but I want it to the
percentage of with fidelity's there ok
there are also some personal benefits
many personal benefits to growing
emotional intelligence it helps reduce
your stress improves productivity helps
you with better relationships increases
your happiness and I know a citation
needed
so we've visit the greater good science
center at UC Berkeley's website because
they have tons of research backs studies
on this so that's why I have new
citation for each one you can do your
research take my word for it or you can
decide I've decided that I don't
necessarily need absolute proof of
something working before I'm willing to
experiment it if it has you know a low
investment so I've also seen these in my
own life okay so assuming now that
you're at least somewhat interested
developing your emotional intelligence
let's talk about how to do it so I like
to use a metaphor that's not unfamiliar
to people intent so hopefully most of
you are familiar with the idea of being
on call I saw so we're the past day
there's been like a lot of discussion on
Twitter people are debating on call I
haven't really been following it but
they're apparently you know most people
understand this idea of being on call
but just to make it clear so if you if
your site goes down or if there's
something there's some kind of problem
on your app or your website somebody
will get a notification probably not on
an actual device like this anymore but
that's you know you're on call so being
a human it's kind of like being on call
all the time and you're distressing
emotions are like alerts and similar
similarly to how when you don't deal
with an alert properly on your system
it's similar to when you do that as a
human disaster strikes so what does it
look like if you don't handle your
remote
channel alerts properly well Daniel
Goldman says out of control emotions can
make smart people stupid and what he
means by that are some examples you
might if you're over if you're very
emotional about something what you might
do is send an email that you later
regret I may or may not have done this
in the past you may send a slack message
that isn't particularly kind you may you
know yell at somebody and say something
that you regret you also just may be so
distracted by how angry you are that
you're not productive it's like so this
is why it's helpful to be able to manage
your distressing emotions and this is
just one aspect of emotional
intelligence but I feel like it
illustrates the bigger picture here so
that's the one we're gonna focus on so
I'd like to present to you an emotional
incident runbook so similar to how when
there's an alert on your system
sometimes you'll have some kind of
runbook you might call it a playbook and
it's a list of things that you can do to
help troubleshoot the site so maybe it's
you know where to look in the logs to
see if something's broken or you know
who to contact about this near that or
what to look for in the database or
whatever it may be to troubleshoot so
I'm gonna do that but for your emotional
incidents so here's the process I'd like
to present which is slowing down tending
to your needs
offering empathy and proceeding calmly
these are steps you can take whenever
you find yourself in the middle of an
emotional incident the spells out stop
which is nice easy to remember so we'll
go through each one in turn the first
one is slow down which is a bit ironic
it's I'm a fast talker and I'm saying
slow down but it's very important so I
took a meditation class a few years ago
and the instructor was talking about how
our anxious mind is kind of like a jar
of water that's full of sediment that's
been shaken up and all of our anxious
thoughts are like the sediment and that
meditation or just slowing down in an
informal way allows the sediment or the
anxious thoughts to settle so that we
have clarity in the jar meaning you can
see through the water but also
metaphorically in your mind you have
more clarity about your situation that's
why it's so important true story I
dropped that meditation class after the
laughs I thought it was moving too
slowly and I thought I'd be remiss and
get it faster so I had a lot to learn
but I think I've made some progress
since then so the next I was tending to
your needs so what are beads what I'm
even in Venice so here are some examples
of needs they come from a book called
nonviolent communication by Marshall
Rosenberg highly recommend this book so
we have basic means like shelter arrest
food safety we also have me it's like
autonomy creativity meaning love respect
trust closeness community fun laughter
beauty order peace so most time you have
spiritual needs these are examples of
needs that meet we could be experiencing
and they definitely affect our emotional
responses so the empathy piece is trying
to understand what the other person is
feeling valuing and eating so you slow
down you understand your needs you tend
to them if you can first you understand
what the other person is feeling and
then you proceed calmly with what you've
decided based on all that information so
I'd like to walk through an example just
because that really helped and this may
be difficult to read so I'm going to
read it out it's actually difficult for
me to read on here so quick you look
closer
but yeah so here's an example of an
exchange between two developers and
please imagine them as whatever gender
you would like I tried to use names that
are commonly used for multiple genders
so the first one says Alex I saw that
you set the points on a story by
yourself again we're supposed to vote as
a team now they're discussing an issue
tracker where you set points on a story
like in them an agile software
development the other developer says I
never agreed to that the story was just
a quick task what does it matter we have
a process in place and we're supposed to
stick to it
you always do that bring up process we
waste so much time talking about process
I just want to get things done and
you're always being reckless and
breaking things we have processes in
place for a reason if you can't stick to
them maybe you shouldn't be on the team
yeah maybe I shouldn't well okay that
escalated quickly
so this is what happens when we don't
apply emotional intelligence we think
we're having a perfectly rational
rational debate about process and this
and that but you can tell people's
emotions are definitely involved here
even if what they're saying you know may
just be could be potentially just raffle
so let's walk through the steps to slow
down so the first is you know just
because you see something that bothered
to you don't just immediately jump in
and try to criticize someone or tell
them why they're wrong right so let's
take a step back and try to unwind this
a bit ok so Morgan sees that Alex have
set the story point without consulting
the team okay so what is it likely that
Morgan values in this situation I would
say that Morgan values order
organization structure process why does
this person value these things well I
would imagine it's because Morgan would
like santaville deliver value to the
customers in organized and productive
efficient way so what is Alex value in
this situation it seems to me like Alex
values moving quickly not getting
weighed down by excessive process and
why would Alex value that well probably
because Alex would like to deliver value
to the customer efficiently and
productively so really if you take the
time to slow down you realize hey we're
both on the same team and probably our
end goal is actually the same so
although we may have some different
values in between we don't need to have
this really hostile exchange okay so
slow down looked at the needs so let's
proceed calmly so let's see how this
conversation could go
so Morgan instead says Alex when I saw
that you set the points on a story
without consulting anyone
I felt concerned because I need to trust
that we share responsibility as the team
can you explain what happened alex says
the story was just a quick one point
task what does it matter
Morgan says it seems like you value
moving quickly and feel that process
sometimes gets in the way is that right
now it says well yeah I don't want to
talk about process I just want to get
things done Morgan says I also want to
get things done it's also important to
me that I feel a sense of order
would you be willing to send a quick
note to the team when you point a story
on your own so that we at least we know
and then Alex says yeah I guess I can do
that so you'll see this example if I
didn't create a magical world where both
people are applying these techniques in
this situation pretty much only Morgan
is applying new techniques but it can
still work so you know and you can reach
a solution where because you remember
what the end goal is you can come to
something that both people can agree
with so I know if you're like me when I
was sort of talking about this what a
waste of time to have to do this in
every conversation well one you don't
have to do it in every conversation
because sometimes you build up rapport
with people so that you don't need to
you're unlikely to have an emotional
incident every single time but when you
do feel yourself getting emotional like
when you feel your heart starting to
beat faster your fight-or-flight
mechanisms are kicking in that's really
when you know that you need to slow down
and work through these steps so giving
you kind of a starter guide to this
emotional incident runbook but like I
said it's a much bigger picture here
with emotional intelligence and you'll
start to notice patterns the things that
you value so much that trigger you and
trigger that emotional response so for
example some people value fairness right
so if something at work happens that
seems unfair which is one of the most
common complaints in the workplace then
you may feel yourself getting emotional
so it's really about just being able to
communicate those needs in a productive
way and it really takes practice a lot
of practice I can tell you somebody
who's had to make this transition but
it's so worth it and the whole time I
think it's important to keep in mind a
growth mindset which means let's not say
I'm not a people person or I'm an
introvert or I'm an engineer I'm not a
manager so why do I have to care about
people but instead they hey these skills
can help me be more effective in my job
so I'm gonna work to develop them over
time and I'm gonna be patient with
myself as I'm learning this so to this
point I would like to at least do a
little bit of exercise a little exercise
with you to give you an example with
this don't worry no one's gonna have to
say anything and we're talked to it's
all gonna happen in here so think about
a time when you lost control of your
emotions so when you yelled at somebody
or you wrote name read email we all we
all do it you know at least in your head
really have gotten angry at somebody I
guarantee it it's not again you can
tackle me at the end of office okay so
think of an incident and if you're
having trouble recalling
something I would say an easy one is
getting stuck in traffic everyone gets
so annoyed in traffic right because
someone cuts you off or someone's not
going fast enough someone's doing
something differently so just I'm gonna
pause for a few seconds and just let you
think and try to try to come call to
mind an incident and again you're not
gonna have to tell anyone about this
though it doesn't matter it's about work
personal life whatever but think about a
time when you feel that maybe you said
something you regret you did something a
little bit on that was clearly motivated
by out of control emotions okay so let's
take it a few seconds
so hopefully you have one in mind dot
you can use the the car one because that
would probably works and if you don't
drive you could think about when you've
had to wait in a really long line
perhaps at the DMV or somewhere else you
couldn't get the DMV if you don't even
if you don't drive I guess but or like
maybe in line at a amusement park or
something
okay so then keeping in mind that
instead they thought of what would have
happened if maybe you'd slowed down okay
think about what were your needs in that
moment so let's see in the traffic
example so when I'm stuck in traffic and
I actually get more upset when
somebody's like tailgating me because I
just i've been rear-ended before and so
i kind of have this fear around that so
when somebody is tailgating me what i
feel is fear i feel fear
I feel annoyance because I'm like don't
they know that there's certain following
distance that we learned when we took
into a driver's test and we're supposed
to be following that and I actually
drive quickly so it's surprising to me
even in when it happens but anyway so
that's what I'm valuing so then you know
I could just say oh what a jerk right
but that's what we're gonna do here so
we're gonna think okay offer empathy why
is this person tailgating me what are
they feeling value me in needing well I
suspect that they are trying to get
somewhere quickly maybe they're in a
rush because of something you know
distressing happening in their life
maybe it's just trying to get home to
see their family for some reason they're
in a hurry maybe they have a bad day and
they feel powerless and this is you know
tailgating me it's how they're trying to
assert their dominance I don't know what
it is but I can I can think about these
possibilities to help build empathy I
can proceed calmly so what are my
options
yeah I could just like slam drinks right
but I try to avoid that I do sometimes
tap but not in an annoying way like more
and just like you know I'm scared way
but but again I can't control how its
how its interpreted but maybe I can
change lanes maybe I could get off I
could actually get off they at the
highway take an exit and then maybe you
know try again and hope for the best
there are things I could do but what I'm
not gonna do is get angry and I'm not
going to you know try to get behind them
and then Hoggart or you know flash my
brides or something I'm gonna do
something calmly so in your situation
see you you know
what were you meeting
no what were you meeting and what was
the other person needing and if no one
else was involved you can just focus
more on what you were needing or what
you know how you were reacting to yours
to your situation so again let's take it
to you second three using like I use
that example that's to try to help but
since I was talking about full time it
would've been hard for you to do both
parts so I'm gonna pause again kind of
think about what you were needing in
that distressing moment that you thought
of and what anyone else involved in that
situation was meeting
so again you don't have to share you can
just think think of that and I would try
to do that on a daily basis and again it
takes time because there's so much to
Annoying stuff that happens in life
there gonna be people who have totally
different values from you that do really
things that just really irritate you
because of your values so you know just
try to remember on daily basis to try
its member to stop and implement these
steps the last time I get this talk I
step three was empathize so it's spelled
step and I realized that didn't really
make sense and I was like wait a second
I have to change it to offer empathy and
stops I'm pretty happy with this kind of
thing okay so yes emotional intelligence
helps you become more effective as an
individual yes it can help build more
effective teams but I think there's a
bigger picture here I think the problems
were facing intact all relate to this
lack of concern for human beings and by
problems were facing in tech I mean yeah
it's the lack of inclusion and diversity
yes the fact that there's a lot of
unethical choices made in tech yes the
fact that we're building products that
can be addictive and that can be hurtful
to society and I think all of that
relates to a lack of concern for human
beings so that I think that's the bigger
picture here you Karen Armstrong says it
all
she writes if it is not tempered by
compassion and empathy reason can lead
men and women into a moral void and I
would say that's what happened in tech
right now because we've been so obsessed
with just a technical side to logic the
reason we really love compassion and
empathy go by the wayside and because of
that we've really created a moral void
in tech so this is a meditation garden
that's near me where I live in Encinitas
and I liked I didn't take this picture
because I thought it would be like not
cool to break out my phone at a
meditation pardon so I got this one your
website but I go there and it's a
beautiful view of the ocean and they
have this little booklet and I read this
quote and it really spoke to me if I
want to share it with you when people
speak of political social or
international problems they often do not
realize that these conditions are
nothing more than the accumulated
thoughts and actions of millions of
individuals and the only way to change
world conditions is to change ourselves
so I really think the even bigger
picture is this is not just about tech
applying these skills of emotional
intelligence can be so important it can
be so powerful to create a more peaceful
world
where we actually care enough about each
other to understand where
from and we could make a really big
difference here so with that thank you
very much I did take this picture
awesome movies this one I can take
credit for
here's my newsletters that compassionate
coding comm it's also my website blog
posts stuff like that I'm going to be
having a course on how to avoid burnout
and tag coming out soon so please sign
up if you're interested in any of that
we're just getting free resources or
staying in touch for whatever thank you
very much
[Applause]